où
[Musique]
je m'appelle angela brothers je suis la
dirigeante du magasin et cosy qui se
situe à voisins le bretonneux dans les
yvelines c'est un magasin de décoration
d'objets et de mobilier
[Musique]
c'est plutôt un bus le style industriel
ou quoi être sur le bois le métal et le
bois et mme schick one chic mais aussi
également j'aime beaucoup les produits
naturels j'essaye vraiment de trouver
des des petites perles comme j'appelle
des petites choses que qu'on voit pas
trop ailleurs
[Musique]
le concept du magasin c'est aussi
d'avoir des jeunes créateurs à qui je
fais appel et pour lesquelles je suis en
dépôt-vente nous qui viennent ma porte
leur création ce sont principalement des
vies si noir j'ai un céramiste
j'ai une jeune fille qui a créé pendant
prochainement en fait une idée de tissus
à trouver passer ces tissus mous quel
point elle fait de la de l'aquarelle
ensuite elle confectionne elle même ses
poussins et on à mes petits chouchous
qui sont les vieilles branches
l'idée c'est vraiment de récupérer au
maximum de choses est de redonner vie à
des objets
[Musique]
j'étais dans l'édition depuis 25 ans
mais c'est vrai qu'à mes 20 ans j'ai
toujours dit j'adore la déco j'adore les
activités manuelles et au moment du
confinement je me suis aperçu par
feuille de route ma vie filet entre la
route le stress être à temps pour
récupérer les enfants
être à temps pour faire plein plein de
choses et ça je me suis dit mais je peux
plus vivre comme ça et du coup il y
avait une boutique qui s'était libéré
donc c'était pas celle ci une boutique
qui s'est libéré et d'assumer mais c'est
bien ça fait 2 ans que tu que tu la
regardes ça fait deux ans qu as tu fait
de l'oeil il faut que tu ailles te
renseigner et vasil leur histoire
[Musique]
de chercher en fait toujours chercher le
petit truc qui va plaire à mes clients
qui me plaît à moi aussi bien sûr qui
est là de toute façon à la base ça me
plaît à moi mais alors quel bonheur de
voir les gens rentrent et il me dire à
ces super j'adore votre ambiance j'adore
être chez vous
[Musique]